[Music]
mitch is with us mitch is in phoenix hi
mitch how are you
i'm great dave
good what's up
so um
i'm a smaller general contractor i
specialize in uh small to medium large
uh
commercial construction projects
and um one of the things we've been
having trouble this last year is cash
flow a big time with you know with
delays and material and just labor
shortages like everything just cash flow
and it's been really hard to try and
catch up um
we've been we've paid off a significant
amount of debt over the last 18 months
even through all these issues but still
are having cash flow problems and
one of the solutions my wife and i have
been kicking around and it's kind of
bittersweet is to sell our house um to
help out with the problems we've been
having and
we you know uh we're and
so yeah
okay if you have a labor shortage
then you don't have money going out for
labor how does that create a cash flow
problem
um well we're pushing on large
commercial projects we can be out
anywhere from 60 to 90 days worth of
labor so yes we have a labor shortage um
you know which is causing us to not be
able to hire the amount of employees we
need to do the work so it's causing me
to go out in the field instead of doing
my job in the office if that makes sense
but that doesn't cause cash flow
problems
um
you're right it's it's putting out the
money for 60 to 90 days so but you're
not putting out the money because the
people aren't working because there's a
shortage
okay well i i misspoke i apologize i'm
just i'm trying to understand because
that's just okay so
uh but but what is happening is your
contractors are jerking you around more
than ever
yeah
well no so we're subject so we're
general contractors specializing in
we're sub for all intents our purposes
so we subcontract we do um
we do millworks construction and door
and hardware is what we specialize in
but we're a general contractor okay so
you go and you inside but you go and you
install
millwork and doors and then it's it's 60
to 90 days before you get paid
yep yeah so and that's the way it's
always been
that's the way it's always been and it
got worse during covid because of the
banks weren't coming these are all bank
finance projects that they're anywhere
from like okay so i'm back to
your contractor that brought that
brought you in to put the windows and
doors in is jerking you around because
the bank's jerking him around jerking
his client around and they're so they're
throwing you out another 30 or 45 days
beyond what your business model used to
be
yeah you know as you know if they say
crap rolls downhill yeah it does and so
your problem is your house isn't gonna
fix your price that's right
that's exactly you're right and like
you're you're completely right you have
a business model that you have a
business model that's broken yeah
okay so you are going to have to quit
taking bad business
and bad business is business that does
not pay on time
okay now you have a broken business
model and so you're gonna have to go
contractors who are gonna jerk me around
who are not gonna pay their bill on time
are not gonna get my services
because i would rather do nothing
than work for somebody and not get paid
on time and get my tail in a crack
yeah and and it's gotten better dave
like no no stop it
you're getting you call we have to sell
your own home to fix this business model
problem now you're defending it
well
i i agree i guess i guess the amount of
equity in the house was just
a thought process yeah you know
what it is your trip my problem is
you're treating the symptom not the
problem yes yes yes
and and i think you're also ignoring how
much leverage you have mitch do you not
feel you have leverage i mean they need
you to get the job done there's a reason
why you're in business because
contractors aren't doing that work am i
right
yeah and
and there really is and like and like i
said it it's not like every project's
that it's like we've come off a
significant amount no i just told you
you've been dealing with bad ones and
good ones you need to fire the bad ones
and your cash flow problems are going to
go away call their bluff mitch
if they need you as much as i think they
well 50 percent up front yeah 50
depositor i don't show up yeah because
you've not been paying on time that's
exactly right you've got more leverage i
just changed my terms with you there's
cash on delivery yeah because you don't
pay your bills
or don't
i'd rather not take the job take fewer
jobs make better margin with people you
want to work with that pay on time
that you know all right
say no
that's
that's that's why i'm calling in but i i
also was trying to
you know maybe find a way to help pay
off pass the debt you know from the
business and be able to have a safety
net
you know what i mean to be able to take
those hits
you know
i don't want you to take those hits
i want you to turn this business model
over where they take the hits not you
yeah
listen i've got a friend that makes
that'll make a million dollars net
profit this year on a remodeling company
he does residential remodeling
if you want him to come into your house
and do remodeling do you know what you
have to do
50
up front before he sets foot on the
dadgum job
yeah
he's not he's not he's not cash flowing
his customers
needs their cash flowing their own needs
and he's simply executing the work
but he's demanding oh and by the way
he's a phenomenal contractor yeah
the work gets done and it is pristine
and he's making
bank here's the deal mitch i'm just
going to shoot you straight uh
you're in one of the hottest real estate
markets in the country
in what is one of the most historically
high opponents real estate yeah yeah no
pun intended and you have leverage you
need to start acting like it dave's
exactly right you need to man up and
just tell these guys stop screwing
around or i'm going to hold your doors
or i'm going to hold this i'm not going
to do and you go find somebody else
who's not going to do the job that i'm
going to do this has to stop today it
has to stop i got a 50 million
commercial project going right on the
hill right here right now and i'll
guarantee you if i don't
i'm the customer and i've got a
commercial general contractor up there
doing it and when we sit down and do pay
and it's 2 million bucks if i don't
write that check you know what happens
to work up there it stops that's exactly
right and that's not because they're bad
guys no it's our deal yeah i'm they're
not they're not my bank yeah
and i'm not i'm my bank yeah and the
their job is to build stuff not speaking
up you're you're playing banker here
yeah and and so you know you've just
gotta you need to cut out about 10 of
your customers and they're causing 90 of
your problems yep
and then the other
uh on about another 15 or 20 of your
customers need to be taught new tricks
yeah and you don't have to be a jerk but
you can be direct i don't know you could
be direct and go hey look this stops
it's not it's not being unkind it's just
going this is the deal that's right my
buddy that gets 50 up front he's not a
jerk no he's a kind he's a wonderful man
he's a craftsman
but um but you but he's not working for
you
unless you put the he's not your bank
yeah and don't tell me the banks are
flush with cash right now no no no no
they were jerking people around during
covered
coke they they were not yeah
they were sitting at home with their
thumb in their ear instead of going to
work
and they were not issuing checks on
these construction loans and so the
construction loans were not going out to
the owner and and the construction and
then the owner wasn't paying the general
right and the general's not paying his
subs but that's not the end and he's
right crap rolls downhill and it rolls
downhill from bank of america that's
what it rolls right so uh because
there's a big load of it over there to
roll downhill so um
but that's just you know that's the way
that that that actually was happening
yeah right
now but here's the thing you got a
general contractor that's doing a 50
million dollar project he's got some
bank he'll find the money if the door is
going to store guys trust me
he's got so much leverage you you're
you're let's sell your house i want you
to throw your shoulders back and strut
around a little bit more so seriously oh
man you you got the stuff
you're you're in the driver's seat more
than you think you are please don't sell
your house to fix those people's
problems
please don't do that
please please don't
you may want to sell it for other
reasons but don't do it for that reason